I should have stopped him I need to
think about my family your job is to
wrestle live up to that deal where we
are
through I told you to look out for him I
just love being out there with you guys
it's the only thing that matters to me
the V will forever be the greatest
family in the history of
wrest I know you grew up a fan of the
Von Erics you knew this story I'm
interested in
like really particularly the desire to
make a movie about them it's not an easy
subject to make a movie about so what
was the impulse specifically to do it
this way well I don't like to try and
make easy movies so not that there are
any easy movies but I think it just
touched on all the things I was
interested in and have you know
furthering themes I've explored in
earlier films um about family why we
believe what we believe where we come
from questioning where we come from um
but it's also about Sports and
athleticism which is something I've
always wanted to explore and wrestling
in particular was a world that I feel um
doesn't get portrayed often and doesn't
get portrayed well often uh which is
also something that that draws me to to
to making films it's like if I feel like
I can um bring a new light to it or more
depth to something um I'm drawn to do so
and um I think with wrestling in
particular I hadn't really seen you know
these guys are in the ring and they are
acting out the highest highs the lowest
lows you know acts of Injustice it's
like a full range of huge emotions but
when they go home or they go backstage
the sort of box they're put in as men is
to keep their emotions inside and that
was um something that really I connected
to and something I felt was was
important to explore uh even if this is
an extreme version of that feels like
something that feels very
important in terms of working on the
screenplay can you talk about really
figuring the structure of this movie out
I mean given the really just tragic
nature of the story um I I would imagine
there was a lot of nuance to be found
within those beats and and figuring out
exactly how to get from point to point
here yeah I mean when I when I first
because I knew I knew a certain amount
from childhood and I remembered a
certain amount but really as I as a
filmmaker as I started to do research
and look into it and sort of lay out the
timelines and as many facts as I could
gather which in the world of wrestling
it's hard to find facts there's a lot of
Gossip there's a lot of myth uh and so
that in itself was one thing but but
basically what I was looking at was this
epic Greek tragedy uh it was you know of
mythical proportion you know so it was
it was more um what do you include how
do you include it how do you find the
core of the story and um it was just
making those tough decisions along the
way of of what to include so how did you
think about casting broadly I know know
you didn't necessarily go in with any
like you know expectations of a physical
regimen obviously I needed to train in
the wrestling department but like what
were you looking for
emotionally um I always just look for
something um I don't know it's an
instinctual thing sort of one thing that
allows me to see the person in the role
and um sometimes it'll come from seeing
them in something else or it could come
through the casting process um and it's
usually confirmed in a conversation of
just meeting someone and and just
energetically feeling that they have the
thing and I and and you know trusting
that they are the the person for it so
Zach can you talk about meeting Sean and
and that initial discussion about this
uh pretty demanding intense part
remember meeting Sean for the first time
in New York uh for you know uh and he he
B he basically told me a story that was
the backdrop of wrestling but really
underneath it it was a really beautiful
story
about um loss you know and about family
and the lengths that one man is willing
to go for the people that he loves
there's something in instinctual about
it I I really enjoyed the way Shawn
talked about making a movie and about
the characters the Nuance that he was
excited about
in telling this story that's fascinating
you know and so fun to uh to engage it's
it's all on the page and I know it's in
his mind but kind of Excavating it just
seemed like a really really fun and uh
challenging uh undertaking especially
with Kevin the emotional load is really
um dramatic how did you find like
stepping into that holding that onset
was it difficult painful to to kind of
go through those scenes in that whole
process during the shoot the physical
prep was probably the most uh grueling
part of all of it that literally was
painful uh there was no way around it
all the wrestling and just the getting
into Kevin's body was was really
challenging I mean it it was months of
of uh training and you know just a
preparation really focusing in a way
that I had never never done before uh
for any role the other really
fascinating thing in talking with Shan
about uh you know Kevin's position in
the family and this very interesting
trait which was that he didn't really
excel in the Limelight that really
wasn't where he shined he was just
electric as a wrestler but in the
Showmanship quality that was something
that didn't necessarily come naturally
to him and I thought that was a really
cool color also just the ability to to
get with these guys these really
fantastic actors and work out a
complicated sad uh but ultimately really
beautiful uh family story was really
exciting Jeremy you're you come into the
film a little bit later um and and are
thrust really back into this family
Dynamic this wrestling World um pretty
abruptly how did you think about car's
Arc in the film and that particular
moment when you do take Center Stage uh
before of course things start to go very
wrong yeah I mean it's interesting the
the story of the Von Erics there there's
so much like sort of like Destiny and
fate and tragedy and and all of these
things and and often times I I I would
think about the brothers like other
possible paths um you know um for for
carry it was it was the Olympics um for
for Kevin it could have been football at
a time and and um and yeah it seems like
they were all they were all drawn uh
into this um into this thing and and and
um and and very much LED there by their
father and I think their identity got so
tied up in in wrestling and then
therefore like all all sort of approval
and and and selfworth for a period I
think was then attached to each other
but but but also um also you know also
uh also Fritz so it's it's interesting
to think about you know I guess um what
could have what could have been you know
for for these men yeah yeah and Stanley
with with Mike he's a very different
person physically even so how did you
think about the way the kind of space
you would take up in this movie and the
way this character was in this movie The
Music Scene was was uh something that I
was working on for a minute and I think
that really grounded me I was playing a
lot of guitar um just on offset um and
um you know go going back to uh what you
were saying before about like the the
familial I mean like I I think that you
kind of saw like the in the
garage uh they were working out and I
was sitting down drawing in in my
notebook that th those scenes were I
don't know they kind of they they they
grounded me and grounded the character
and I think that um I I you know my Mike
at least in the film wasn't necessarily
the um most
uh uh physically uh you know Adept but I
think that um his his his love for his
brothers really really spoke to me and
and uh hopefully I I I let that uh shine
in in the film Hol uh I want to go to
you and really get your perspective on
the patriarch of this family on on Fritz
there is this feeling as the tragedies
Mount and there's a lot of Silence in
those scenes and and you you carry that
and I'm just curious how you thought of
him and how he was feeling as the film
progressed and and how you wanted to
play it you you know if you uh if you
read the so-called wrestling experts and
you listen to the podcasts and you watch
some of the documentaries um you'll hear
a lot of people say a lot of very
disparaging things about Fritz that he
was controlling that he exploited family
tragedy for commercial gain I think
that's a gross oversimplification of you
know uh who the guy really was I
remember seeing a a you know a brief
clip um after Kevin von Eric saw the
film for the first time and and he said
um you know I didn't think they'd be
able to find an actor to play
Fritz but they found one and that meant
more to me than any review yeah from any
critic could have meant especially
because you mentioned earlier not uh
loving all past depictions of wrestling
so on a really technical level like what
kind of feel did you want to create and
how did you go about accomplishing that
every wrestling scene was shot with the
emotion in mind so we would block it and
you know plan the camera moves the same
way we would as if it was a dinner scene
making the emotional decisions about the
camera that that best serve it without
getting too caught up in the action and
the stunts and stuff and so that so one
of the things that I asked of all these
guys was that they could wrestle the
entire match so that we could go through
the full emotion of whatever it was they
were performing or you know feeling
underneath the performance um so that we
could capture it you can definitely feel
that you guys did that yeah that was a
little more more challenging than a
dinner
scene fair enough well thank you all so
much thank you all for coming thank you
thank you so much thanks
[Applause]
guys